[Music]
from Human theeran Tim Burton and the JK
rolling of his time comes the sort of
goth trial you get whenever Burton Deb
and Helena bonam Carter join forces wow
they're pale even by British standards
Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory you know and love the original
willly Wonka oh musical fantasy about
punishing children till only the pure
remain lightened by Jean Wilder's
effortless charm and some Unforgettable
[Music]
songs legs are he broke but since the
70s version is close to Perfect all they
could add was upsetting CGI and 20
minutes of orthodontic themed backstory
please don't do this in the prequel
that'll be a huge waste of Timmy See's
precious face watch Johnny Depp take a
swing at the iconic role of Wonka a man
struggling with the completely madeup
profession British dentist no son of
mine is going to be a chocolate growing
up in the reverse bear trap from sa LED
Wonka to start a candy company/ torture
Factory and become an extremely awkward
Manchild good morning star Shine the
Earth says hello
yes he may have the same Talent Fame
look and daddy issues of a late '90s
Michael Jackson but de claims that had
zero influence on his performance and to
that we
[Laughter]
[Music]
say meet the bucket family who
ironically don't have a pot to piss in
even though keeping four pensioners
locked up in bed should get them what
3,000 quid a month there's Dad who got
screwed out of a job at the screwing
Factory Helena bonam Carter who appears
like Beetlejuice when you say Johnny
Depp's name three times Grandpa Joe
who's still a mooch but in this version
Wonka can him with no severance did you
get your job back no so he should really
be pissing in the chocolate instead of
sucking up to him and Charlie a perfect
little angel with zero personality glad
he got to let loose later on at least I
am a
surgeon I am a surgeon join Charlie on
his tour of the Chocolate Factory
alongside the human avatars of
gluty avarest Daddy I want another Pony
Pride that kid it's going to be me
because I'm a winner and wrath die die
die where Wonka shows them all the
latest Innovations in indentured
servitude from his food handling rodents
to the indigenous tribe he purchased
while dressed like a British colonial
officer don't worry they like working
around the clock for literal
beans it's not like he treats them like
actual
slate well it's not like he's doing
potentially fatal experiments on I've
tried it on like 20 OA Loompas and each
one ended up as a blueberry oh boy this
isn't good is it uh wonda
forever
gasp as it turns out this maniacal CEO
has an alterior motive wow didn't see
that coming his actual plan find the
right child to take over his
all-consuming job either the one who's
the most pure of heart I invited five
children to the factory and the one who
was the least rotten would be the winner
or the one who's the most obedient and
therefore easiest to groom same diff as
Charlie wins a lifetime of work with
with a Mercurial partner and his army of
slaves of course Charlie takes the job a
child with options would never put up
with this if you hate gum so much why do
you make it you really shouldn't Mumble
cuz it's kind of starting to bum me out
so strap in for a Charming family film
that doesn't really like children I'm
Bard I don't care overweight people kid
who finds the first ticket will be fat
fat fat and
foreigners
but hey Wang Doodles that's a funny word
right porn swaglers and snaz wangers and
those terrible Wicked Wang Doodles hey
Danny Elfman can you Whimsy up some fun
music real quick it's getting kind of
dark
again
starring the sad Hatter a candy cane
Saruman the whitening cile Jo Cabin Boy
dos bloat Salt Bay I came here to kick
ass and chew bubble gum and I still have
my bubblegum screen junkie how Hollywood
saved money before Ai and Helen a bonam
cabbage The Hunger
Games oh I forgot we're making a YouTube
video with Johnny deinit by law I'm
required to add Amber Her destroyed sjw
and tear react challenge or they won't
put it in your recommendations hey
screen junkies are you ready to hold
Willy Wonka accountable for his crimes
we had a real lawyer do exactly that and
tell us exactly how marshmallow fluffy
would be in a court of law what is the
OA loopa song for the police are here
and we need to be
free click the Box on the right to watch
now Good Morning Starshine the Earth
says
hello this is the tale of Captain Jack
Sparrow I sell Christmas trees on Roo
drive we had a wamb bam shangle Lang
this was voted word of the year